hey guys in this video we're going to talk
about collagen and the types of collagen there's
actually over 28 different types of collagen
we're not going to cover all of them I'm gonna
cover five of them okay now what is collagen it's
the type of protein and it's the connective tissue
it comes from the Greek word which means glue
because it holds everything together as a mesh
as a like a matrix of strands okay so number
one the type one is the most abundant 90% of
all of the collagen is this type and it forms scar
tissue it forms the tendons the ligaments the bone
is made out of collagen with minerals to make
it solid the teeth are also a lot of collagen
in there certain parts and calcium and then we
have skin in arteries okay that's type 1 tattoo
is all the joint cartilage and their articular
surfaces that connect on that joint so if you
were to have a joint that's wore out you would
want to probably take more of the two versus maybe
weak ligaments that's a whole different thing okay
Type three is the connective tissue the collagen
that is like the mesh around the liver inside
the liver that separates the different things
it's more delicate it's in the bone marrow it's
in the lymph okay that's three okay four forms
the respiratory tract and that's involved in
the bronchial tubes the lungs the around the
intestines the tissue around the heart the tissue
around the intestines okay that's type 4 and then
type 5 forms the hair and the cell surfaces okay
those are the different types so anytime you're
buying collagen there's different types you can
you can buy it from different sources sometimes
collagen comes from chicken sternum sometimes it
comes from bone marrow sometimes it comes from
fish skin sometimes it comes from pig skin so it
comes from many different sources now the question
is is it just a matter of consuming collagen to
put the collagen back not necessarily there's a
couple really important things you need to know
if your vitamin C deficient you will not be able
to metabolize collagen collagen will not form
in the body - Ella you're gonna have weakness
within the ligaments the cartilage and just if
you take a look at a vitamin C deficiency called
scurvy for example what's happening they have
a lot of collagen loss they have bleeding gums
their teeth are falling out what is that well
what happens vitamin C is necessary to form the
collagen very very tightly it's because if you
don't vitamin C it can leak blood and that's
called micro hemorrhaging it's the same exact
thing that people have in their arteries so if
they have like a clogged artery for example the
first thing that happens is a micro hemorrhage
hemorrhaging so you have the bleeding the
cholesterol comes the calcium comes forms a
plaque that's because they have a small version
of scurvy in the arteries so what happens is if
you gave them type 1 collagen it might not work
what they need is the vitamin C so vitamin C is
very important and with collagen make sure that
you get a natural version if you're using some
synthetic it better come with a lot of flavonoids
or other factors okay number 2 gastric bypass if
you have a gastric bypass what's happening
is you're not going to be able to digest the
collagen as well because your stomach is not as
big and it's altered the physiology is altered
so you might have loose skin it's hard to get the
skin back lastly is low stomach acids if you don't
have enough stomach acid you can't digest the
collagen so you can't even pull it in to break
down the collagen that is going through your
mouth whether its food or supplement it's not
breaking down at the stomach level so it never
gets broken down to the small particles now how
do you know if you have low stomach acids well
you're gonna have gas maybe an iron deficiency b12
deficiency indigestion acid reflux and that could
be a clue that you need more stomach acid and all
of a sudden the collagen that you're consuming
from your food is working ok so just want to kind
of give you some insights and call it different
collagen types and it might not be a matter of
just consuming collagen you might have to look at
these other factors alright thanks for watching